I've been fired from a tour because at  that time they straight up told me I was  too fat what yeah must be in Asia just  gave birth it sounds like Asia it is a  lawsuit I don't want to have to talk  about the choreographer or even the  artist but if you want to you could just  lay it all out  [Laughter]  I call like my friends in the industry  but they're like girl you know you can't  be fat and I'm like that was their  response yeah but I was like you're  right and then I went to like major  depression  it's real though it was real depression  the body shaming's crazy one time they  had all the girls get in the line and  turn around and they literally just  looked at our butts and then they were  like thank you for coming I was like  they're like nobody here has an ass it's  like a real it's a real she's like it  was a Fruit of the Loom commercial so I  don't get it okay  oh that's